throughout the month and during this
newscast we've been sharing stories
about the remarkable women of southern
nevada these four ladies were
highlighted out of nearly a hundred
nominees and one of them will be chosen
to participate in the next star woman of
the year show
and i am so excited to announce that out
of all the incredible stories that we've
heard and the ones that we've shown you
the remarkable woman from las vegas
is kristin schuler heights
congratulations
and i have something for you these
beautiful flowers right here kristen
are for you to take home
are you surprised came absolutely
gobsmacked are you really did did we
keep the secret that i am totally in
completely i
what the other ladies have done is so
remarkable and what i do is just such a
small portion i i just i
oh i'm so glad you're surprised but you
know what you shouldn't be because what
you do is remarkable and you now join a
nationwide virtual event recognizing
women from cities all across the country
i mean you are in an esteemed group of
remarkable women you really are i thank
you so much i i don't even know
we made a lawyer speechless
that is a rare thing to do but you know
what you don't have to say anything for
a few minutes because we're going to
have some people talk about you
and congratulate you we want to
celebrate you and all that you've done
so
we have you know you help people during
the pandemic you have so many causes
that you contribute to your time and
devote your energy to to make people's
lives so much better let's bring in our
klas general manager jay howell he has a
special gift to share with you
that you may want to share with one of
your charities
congratulations kristin i'm being named
our remarkable woman for las vegas we
know you spent a lot of time helping
struggling nevadans navigate staying in
their homes and senior citizens getting
their code vaccines and we think this
should help out with your cause on
behalf of kls tv8 and next star media
group
we are thrilled to present you with a
chair your charity with a check for one
thousand dollars thank you for the
amazing work you are doing in our
community
wow
[Applause]
jerry i'll send it back to you i
understand we have a special message
from another remarkable woman yes we do
jay a couple of remarkable women as a
matter of fact thank you for that i mean
i think you can find a place for a
thousand dollars to go can't you i can
yes
well a woman who is so supportive of
this program and all that we do uh a
couple of ladies
important ladies from cbs first up is
cbs morning's co-host gail king would
like to say something
hey hey kristen talking to you
congratulations on being one of the most
remarkable women of las vegas that's you
besides your everyday job as an attorney
you work seven days a week making sure
people are able to get their homes
during these very uncertain times plus
you've gone out of your way to help
vulnerable seniors stay safe during this
pandemic and if that's not enough you
still find time i don't know how to stay
involved with several charities near and
dear to your heart
i'm exhausted kristin just reading this
so bravo to you with all of that you are
not even looking to be acknowledged for
doing what you think we all should do
and that is why you are truly and i love
this word remarkable congratulations
bravo give yourself a round of applause
kristin
wow
thank you gail i love gayle's words she
always puts everything right in
perspective well here's another special
greeting from someone else another very
special woman from cbs evening news hi
kristen norah o'donnell here well from
all of us here at the cbs evening news
want to wish you a heartfelt
congratulations on being chosen as this
year's remarkable woman in las vegas and
your nomination for next star's woman of
the year award that's awesome thank you
for all the terrific work you do to
improve the lives of so many wow
thank you norah
she is a terrific news anchor she finds
a way to make herself giving herself as
well so those ladies think a lot about
you and so do your friends and family
and they're very proud of you and we've
gathered them here today
just a handful because you have so many
but they are in the studio to join in
the fun and support you and surprise you
so
uh kristen tell us a little bit about
now you and i have talked a lot but the
viewers at home don't know much about
the other causes that you support and
tell us what's near and dear to your
heart and what motivates you
any animal charity
i can't stand a homeless dog
a
foster adopt go to the shelters clear
the shelters
we donate to anything to do with
aids research brain research i'd like to
see alzheimer's wiped out as a matter of
fact my brother's
wife's mother is dealing with
alzheimer's and the fact that we have
lou revo here to help and work so hard
on curing
alzheimer's that is just
wonderful i can't say enough good things
about lou revo
we've done
always got to bring up the show girl
picture yeah well hey i think you should
be proud of that picture i sure would be
you have the you're participating in the
aids walk coming aids walk yes um there
is not a auction
that i go to if there's a prize that has
not been bid on my job is to make sure
that price gets bit on there should be
nothing that's donated that does not go
home with someone and my friends and
family have been the recipients of many
what is this gifts it's like i want it
just take it
somebody needed it it looks great there
well we want to say congratulations
again you have a big heart for giving
you work extra hard there need to be
there needs to be 25 five hours in a day
just for kristen schuler-heinz so thank
you thank you to your husband jeff for
nominating you and all your friends and
family who support you
i think they know that you give a whole
whole lot of yourself so we're very
proud of you and you've done all that
working volunteering heavily involved in
community events and also we've got
those three other remarkable women that
we featured the stories on those are all
listed on our website and oh my gosh
we've just had so much fun
and we'll be back
with more news and weather after this
but please go to our website if you
haven't had a chance to look at all of
these ladies stories including our
winning remarkable woman christopher
kristen schuler